is all like a boxer with scar tissue
you punch you right in the face you
split up that old wound again and start
leaking from that same cut again
we want y'all to get into a fight and
don't get hit like me and Cog got boxes
that we know he real good if he don't
get punched in the face
just don't touch that [__] just just
yeah just just watch out for the scar
tissue big class says signed the
contract and and and and Maddie Maddie
alluded to that it's the cascading
effect
right what is this going to affect down
the line it's never a one-off with you
guys never it's never you've marketed
this game at 60 frames per second I can
go back to every video it's been 60
frames I've said yo look at his 60
frames I'm amped every time you showed
it you showed it in the best like 60
frames